-Earlier today we sent our pal
Emma Chamberlain
down to the 30 Rock plaza
to give out
some free coffee to New Yorkers.
But in order to get a free cup,
they had to give her
something in return --
their deepest secrets.
This is "Barista Confessions."
Check it out.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Barista confessions ♪
-So, are you willing to tell me
a secret
in exchange for a coffee?
-I think for a coffee, I will.
-Okay. Let's hear it.
-My grandparents,
my mom-mom and pop-pop,
they met in prison.
-Badass. Badass.
-Thanks so much, girl.
-Thank you so much.
-Not many people know
but I accidentally set
just a random stranger, a
woman's, hair on fire at a bar.
Yeah. I was doing a trick
with a matchbook.
-Okay.
-And I guess she had
a lot of hair spray.
-Totally flammable.
-She went up.
-You really deserve a coffee.
-Thanks.
-So I listened to the advice of
a witch on TikTok.
Now I have the name of a guy
I used to hook up
with two years ago in a jar full
of maple syrup under my bed.
-Obsessed.
-He was supposed to be
"stuck on me."
-I have a really gorgeous aunt.
But in middle school I took
her photo
and all of her personal
information
and I made multiple Jdate
profiles with it.
So not one but two men
named Simon
have invited her
to live in Israel.
-So you're gonna get
one of these.
-Thank you.
-I hooked up with
my ex-best friend's sister.
-So does your best friend know?
-God, I don't think so.
-Now they do.
-Yeah, I was, like, walking home
from work one day
and I was like three blocks away
from home.
-Yeah.
-And all of a sudden it hits me.
And I'm like, "Oh, no!"
-I know. I've been there.
-"I have to go."
And, like, I pooped my pants.
-This won't help you with
the pooping problem,
but I love this story.
That was good.